Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 19th,
2048 barometric pressure
outside is about 75 both. Um,
welcome. Welcome to another
edition of this. Um,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
It's a God damn podcast. All right.
What are you doing right now?
Are you at the gym? So it's,
somebody told me recently you always
think were cubicles when I can kill,
because some of us are on treadmills.
So hello to all the people on treadmills.
Ah, you're running at this
point and you're just starting.
He just started on your treadmills,
on your treadmill, I should say,
unless you're running on more than one,
I mean you're, that dude is the Douche,
the treadmill Douche in the gym right now.
You know that person who for some reason
I do burn more calories when you go
backwards,
you know?
Or is that some sort of mating ritual
where you get your ball sent fucking blown
the other way and that somehow attracts
the women on the elliptical behind you?
I don't know what it is.
You ever seen these fucking jerk offs?
They run backwards.
Then they go sideways because I got to
have a lot of lateral movement and the
fucking office.
You never know when the boss is going
to call an audible and start pointing to
your side of the fucking tubes.
Right?
Like you turn it around yelling at
cornerback down on the fucking break room.
What are you running sideways for?
Why are you running backwards?
You fuck a Dosha? Then you fall and you
break your tail bone and who do you sue?
Huh? Chicago fitness.
Whatever the fuck you at.
Whatever the fuck you at. Wherever
the fuck your at. Sorry. All right.
You know what?
I have to admit something and I have
to call just to the people of Chicago.
When I pictured somebody in Chicago
running backwards, I pictured, you know,
a fat guy with a mustache in a bear's hat.
You guys really have never outlive
that sketch in my, I guess in my world,
you know Deb bears and I know
nobody says that they're,
they might say a version of it,
but nobody says that. But to me,
you guys were always going to be
those, those, those guys. I mean I,
you probably shouldn't give a
fuck what I think, but you know,
somewhere somewhere there's somebody
in Chicago that does give a shit.
You give a shit.
You know what you guys need to do to
lift just fucking self esteem out there
with that whole second city horse shit.
The next generation of babies that are
born and turn instead of telling them
it's Lake Michigan,
just tell them it's an ocean.
Yeah.
Michigan Ocean Assam Shit.
And maybe you'll have the arrogance of
someone who lives on the coast and people
will start taking you seriously.
Yeah.
What are you going to say
right now? CHICAGO? Huh? Oh,
what about our Chicago Black Hawks talkie?
You're not controlling finance
like they are in New York City.
How many old people are you
stealing from in Chicago right now?
The way they are in downtown Manhattan.
I'm just fucking you.
I know Chicago is one of the most
corrupt fucking cities out there.
You got to give it respect overtly racist
fucking with the finance home is some
of the fucking top mob guys throughout
history and they got the Chicago Black
Hawks. So I will tell you, I don't
think anybody's fucking stopping it,
but I'll get to that later via
the bank and downstairs. Um,
as you said that slowly but surely I'm
getting the fucking house repaired and I
know you think about Jesus Christ
the fuck speak in a lake, Michigan.
When did that water pour into your house?
That was like over a year ago.
Yes it was.
And I fixed the upstairs,
but the downstairs was built
like a fucking tree for.
So what I decided to do was
rather than just rebuild,
what the fuck was there,
I decided to knock it all out and start
from scratch and build what the fuck
should have been there.
And if anybody knows me and they look
at what the Dick Jokes in my act,
you can tell the level of quality that
I expect from that job downstairs.
Hey, is the podcast loud enough
right now? Everybody complaints?
Make my fucking ears heart right now.
How loud I have this turned up.
I think I have it down.
I don't know what the fucking deal is.
I hope it's not going to be overly loud,
but every week somebody goes, dude,
I can't even fucking hear
the tick. Um, so anyways,
this was,
this was my week.
I guess I got to talk about NHL first
because the first thing before all the
bullshit is I watched my boss,
my boss to blue orange.
Uh, absolutely fucking blow it
against the Montreal Canadians.
I'm just going to pause here for all
the feminist French guys clapping their
hands together, like to plant patty
cake with themselves, you know,
with your colorful socks.
Um,
unbelievable that,
that was so fucking embarrassing
to lose that, that series.
It was so fucking like the way we lost it.
It's on bearing the loses the Canadians.
It sucks.
But that was the first
time in a long time.
Hmm.
I'm going to go back to the 80s that I
felt that at like embarrassed turning
point in the series.
I'm going to say Sean Thornton
spraying the water at fucking PK. Suba.
Why would you do that?
Why would you fucking do that for
those of you don't watch hockey?
We were down two games to one
and they won the first game.
So immediately we lost home home, ice
advantage, whatever the fuck that means.
Right? So we went game to, now it's
one one we go into their building,
they win game two they are holding surf.
So we come in,
we got to win game four we fucking winning
game five can we take control of the
fucking series we win.
Game five is Paul Versey told me,
Joe Tory said the two most important games
to win in a seven game series he felt
was game two and game five which totally
makes sense because if you lost game
one you have to win game two or else
you got to win for next five you got to
even that motherfucker,
right?
And then game five you win game five
all you gotta do is win one of two.
You lose game five you got to win
six or seven bill. It's simple math.
We'll believe it or not. Some people
don't know it. So we win game five,
this two and a half minutes to go.
They're judging the Canadians a dejected,
they had the series by,
they'll fucking proverbial balls over
there and they let the Bruins right back
in it and now they're on the verge of
fucking elimination. So what do we do?
What do we do?
Fuck heads that we were one of the people
on our team decides to not only for no
fucking reason.
Spray water at not only
somebody on the other team,
that best fucking player,
the player that the other people probably
rally around because he's fucking the
best guy in the fucking team.
We spray water in his God,
Deb face the dumbest fucking thing you
ever remember those old Batman episodes
in the 1960s where they'd have the guy
off Batman or Robin is this sit for a
cape crusaders but blue bubble and they
will look like they were fucking dead
and the bad guy always did fucked it up
somehow. That was the moment right there.
That was the fucking moment. He
sprays it in that. So then, you know,
you knew they were going to come out
like gangbusters. I said it last week.
I didn't think that they
were going to win game six.
I didn't think we'd get pummeled for
games, for goals to four to nothing.
That's what happened.
They completely dominated wire to
fucking wire dominated that fucking game.
So then we go down to game seven and I
had a, I didn't have a vibe either way.
Are we going to win and we're
going to lose? I didn't know,
but it's not like the old days when the
Canadians fucking owned us. They don't,
they haven't since fucking 1987 despite
what these fucking idiots will, right.
Because they're lazy.
Sportswriters not only is it been even,
we've actually had the better of it for
the last fucking 30 years or so. So,
you know, it was a 16
fucking league. Okay.
With an expansion six was the tail
end of that Horse Shit. All right,
can we get over it already? Jesus. Today
I could share my shelf enough already.
It's fucking over.
He's dead.
And so is everybody else that watched
him give that speech. Um, anyways,
that probably not,
but who gives a fuck?
So we go into game seven and uh,
it's the usual shit.
I don't think I can remember a series
where we miss more fucking open nets,
hit more crossbars. We were
like, I don't know what happened.
I Dunno what the fuck happened.
A couple of our guys couldn't hit the side
of a fucking bar and I still love him.
I don't think they need to shake
up the team. I love that shit.
Whenever you lose a series they'll do, you
know, so, so decisions have to be made.
You got to make some like, like
you, you don't have what happened.
We had a bad fucking
series. So anyways, um,
the game ends in an a handshake line.
Lucita is telling a couple of,
you told a couple of you supposed to just
go through the line and no matter what,
Grit your teeth, good game, good game
graduations, good luck in the next
round, whatever the hey man, you know,
you were great, you got the better of me,
whatever the fuck you supposed to say.
But Luciano did that for a couple of
players and then a couple other players,
he said, I'm going to fucking kill
you, which you're not supposed to do.
And uh, I just wasn't a
good look. The whole thing,
you know, it's fun. It's kind of ironic
that it made fun of how the bad boys,
the bad boy pistons, the fucking cheap
shot out is how they fucking went out.
And they ended up not being in bad
boys that went out like punks when they
didn't shake the bowls hands or
whatever the fuck they were playing.
I don't want troop. When they walked
off, I thought we had elements of that.
Not saying everybody Charo was a
fucking warrior. He was obviously hurt.
The guy looked like me
on skates by game seven.
He was literally falling down out
there. But um, but whatever, man.
Yeah,
I don't like that shit.
I don't like the water bottle.
I don't like that saying that shit in
the line. So it actually in a weird way,
ease the fucking pain because I'm not
one of those fans that fucking hates that
behavior until people on my team do it. I
just, I dunno, I didn't fucking like it.
And, uh, even if it
worked, I didn't like it.
Let's say it worked and we won
the series. I don't, I don't,
I don't fucking like that
shit. So anyways, uh,
congratulations to the Canadians
definitely deserved it.
And as much as I hate people
saying no real classy,
they actually won with class and uh,
you know,
I didn't have a problem with
the guy mocking blue Cheech
fucking pounding of his
chest when he scored an empty net goal.
I mean,
you got to think someone's going to give
you shit for that and you don't let it
get under your skin. And I think they
got under his skin. I still love the guy.
I'm not shitting on him, but they,
they got the better of you and we lost.
So there you go.
And that's how it works.
So now
blue block a rules are now playing the
fucking Canadians and they got fucking
smoked. And the first one, but that
doesn't mean shit. That's just one loss.
How many coaches have you heard say, I
don't care. It's shoving Joe a Chevy Joe.
Joe Joy cop one watch. Oh, we could go
try learn shop from niche law. Shit.
Y'all going in checking game and
tried to get about this one. Um,
which is what I think they're going to do.
And um, my apologies. So
ranger fans because uh,
there's just something about you. I
don't hear that. Bang. There you go.
That's the guys downstairs. Um, I
just, I don't fucking, uh, I just,
I don't believe in the rangers there.
I said it obviously I
believe in your goal tender.
I believe in the energy that
uh, Martin, Saint Martin,
Saint Louis over the fuck you say
his name. I believe in that shit.
I just don't think you have
enough weapons. And then
also I think you're very,
even with the Canadians, despite
that seven to two, I might eat kraut.
I did really well on the first round when
the high seeds play the low seats. Oh,
I was picking them right and left.
This just, I didn't watch a
lot of the rangers this year,
but I'm going to go.
Okay.
Just with the history of both teams,
the exact thing I told you to ignore it
when I was talking about the Canadians
and Bruins,
I'm now going to bring up the Canadian
history because I think it applies in
this one. So send you fucking hate
mail to me. I don't give a shit.
I think it applies where
they evenly fucking matched and
okay.
Because the Canadians have their history
and their history of winning their fan
base expects them to win and
I've seen it in other sports.
When you have a fan base
that believes like that,
they're able to sometime push a
mediocre team up to a higher level.
I'm not saying they're mediocre,
but I think that they're going to,
it's just going to be a different
vibe there tonight when they play.
Hmm.
Like the fans will have that vibe.
We're not going to tolerate you going
down oh two they just don't do it.
Yankee Stadium,
old Yankee stadium had that sound.
I'm still getting used to
the new Yankee stadium,
but the fans know the fucking game.
They know what's on the line.
They're the ones that's the Yankee fans
started that shit with two strikes.
You start fucking clapping, right?
They understand the fucking game.
Canadian fans do the same range of fans.
Great fence.
I would actually say better fans and the
Canadians because they've put up with
being a fucking ranger fan.
But the thing about the rangers and you
got to own up to this range of fear.
Maybe you don't have to, but I feel
don't you fucking you. You are good.
If you're a true range of fan,
you're waiting for the other shoe to drop.
That is the legacy of
the New York Rangers.
So it's a series like this where they
finally turned it around, I guess.
Well I guess they got it when another
fucking cup. Cause other than you know,
you know the deal. I don't need to bring
up your past stats other than the 1994,
I'll do it for people who don't
watch hockey other than 1994. I mean,
you're talking like a fucking talking.
Basically they've won one
cup and 74 years. It's not a
good look. Okay. The first,
you know,
27 years of that,
they were only competing with six other
fucking five other teams. Okay. So, um,
I just feel that the Canadians are going
to be able to power their way through
and uh, somehow in this series, I hope
it's a great series to original six teams.
You got to love that.
And then out in the West you got the
fucking black hawks original six first and
expansion six with the,
uh, the La Kings. And uh,
I feel that that is the Stanley Cup
final right there. Whoever wins that,
um,
I don't know how evenly matched they are.
I think that King's might've been
a little tired in that first game.
It was only three to one, but, uh, I don't
know. I said it a while back. The fucking,
it's the Blackhawks the loose.
I think they have a little bit of a tough
time with the kings and then they just
fuck up either.
The Canadians are the ranges.
That's what I think now if
your or the other teams, you
should be real excited right now because
I don't think I had been right since
the first fucking route.
Okay. Um, all right.
So there's my hockey,
my hockey speak for the week.
Oh, it rhymed. Holy Shit. Hey,
can I hype a couple of things right
now while you have no fucking choice,
you've got to listen to it.
Uh, the all in comedy tour,
the Monday morning podcast
presents the all in comedy tour.
They're going to be yet
hilarity his comedy club.
One of my favorite comedy clubs,
one of my favorite club owners,
nick costs is a work in there.
And um, I, did I say his name
right? I know a nick costs this and,
and then I know nick is a coastus.
One of them pronounces it the wrong
fucking way. One does the real Greek way.
So I say the real Greek ways and I
just fucked the whole fucking thing up.
Anyways, polarities comedy club.
I do not have spell his name.
How about that?
Is that good enough?
They going to be there May 28th through
June 1st for seven shows. Paul, dude,
I called it Versie Paul.
I'm not from New Jersey.
Versie add a fucking doorbell's ringing.
Hang on.
Yeah.
All right. I'm back. It was funny,
it was just some fucking person
coming to the door soliciting,
just sitting there going like, ah, hey,
good evening sir. I graphene sir. Um, uh,
from the fucking Blah, blah, blah at
Fannie Mae's money for political gains.
But man, he goes, I'm actually
in the middle of a business call.
I have to get back and even get
through. And he just goes, all right,
what was that movie with that guy versus,
he was just talking about gay with the
guy's actually a salesman and somebody
calls his house and he does
basically the same thing.
And the guy gives up and he just
goes, that's it. That's your pitch.
This is how you're selling it.
And he fucking gets the guy all amped
up to give him his pitch again. He goes,
Dan. And that's the sales call. The guy's
like, so do you want the paper? He's like,
no, when he fucking hangs up on him.
I know. I've seen the movie anyways.
I was hyping a, I'll hilarity May 28th
through June 1st the all in comedy tour.
See them while you still can.
All on the same stage as is like when
the temptations were actually the
temptations.
Paul don't say I'm from New Jersey.
Versie Joe
the fucking uh,
chairman of the board,
Bartok Rosebowl tailgate legend and cook.
Jason Law head, Cleveland Native.
Jason Law had go down there.
If you just want to see
a great comedy show,
these are the guys that opened up for me.
Um,
when I'm out on the road and all of
them are going to become headline is in
their own right and a,
I dunno when they're all going
to share the same stage again.
This is like when fuck and Frank Dean and
Sammy went out before they were famous.
You know, they were in some supper club
going after some and whore and they said,
hey, what if we all go up
here and see what happens?
That that's what you're going to see
there in Cleveland unless you stay home,
unless you fucking stay home. I also have
something else to promote. I'm doing a,
uh,
I'm doing a very important
charity event in New York City.
All right? It's going to be Monday.
Make sure I get this down right. Monday,
July 14th in Brooklyn,
New York. All right.
It's the, uh, give laugh groove is, uh,
I guess the foundation. It's the
website. Sorry, give, give left.
[inaudible] dot com and a,
they're raising money for having
children. Um, and I'm going to be doing,
I mean, working with James Smith. James
got a bunch of fans from Australia, uh,
international comedian, uh,
doing a little fucking, uh,
co headline and thing at the
green building in Brooklyn,
New York with proceeds going to
feed my starving children. Uh,
oh, for God's sake. Can I
get through a fucking promo?
Speak of the devil. It's Paul
Versey. Hold on one second. Hey Paul.
I'm doing my podcast and I'm actually
right in the middle of hype in your day.
I just got done hyping a date.
Let me call you back.
I said, I'm doing my podcast.
I'll call you right back.
Okay,
cool.
Uh, um, even he can't
hear the fucking podcast.
What's that? Anyways, it's going to be
a at the green building in Brooklyn,
New York. On Monday, July
14th, I'm working with James
Smith and meanwhile, uh,
two phenomenal musicians. Remember that
band I told you about drew with the drew?
We're just,
everybody in there was unreal.
Are you guys sitting out there
watching these fucking reality shows?
Who's the next fucking American idol?
You just want to see musicians who will
fucking making it by getting together
with other great musicians
and making great music.
I highly recommend downloading the drawer,
the drew album,
but I'm drew [inaudible],
drew and JP Bouvier modern,
not modern drama at the Guitar Center.
Drum off winter, Berkeley fucking
phenom. Just an amazing drummer.
Comments. Read tour drummer. They're
going to be setting a record for the, uh,
I guess longest time to
musicians have played together.
It's going to kind of be like, uh, you
know, like a festival kind of thing.
They're gonna be doing that in one room.
You got a comedy show in another room.
We're going to be feeding people.
It's going to be fucking great. Uh,
go to give laughed groove.com
and come on out. Okay. And I'll,
you'll be seeing me bringing
the fucking lumber, uh oh.
And I'll also be a feeding some people to,
I guess whatever.
It's a fucking charity. Whatever they
need me to do, I'm going to do what?
What is it here? What am
I doing here? Where is it?
Where's the copy bill?
Why do you suck so fucking bad at this?
All right.
So as I got you and James signed up
to do the last meal pack of each day,
which is four 30 to 6:30 PM
on July 14th and 46 on six.
Okay. The next day. But we're
performing only on the 14th. Uh,
still cool with this course.
Yeah. Fuck yeah. Absolutely.
All right. So there you go.
That's what the hell I'm doing.
It's a check that shit up. Okay.
Back to the podcast. Um,
all right. So this weekend,
um, I had, uh,
I had a relative
graduated from law school,
so I had to fly back to Boston,
go right.
And every time I go back to Boston,
they fucking build something else and
tore something down that I loved and then
fucking put something else in
place of it. And I go, well,
what happened to it this time?
I went back and he'll,
top steakhouse was fucking closed.
I was on my way up to
giggles comedy club to uh,
I thought only do one show. I did two
shows. I should've kept it at one.
I went into the second room and I didn't
realize that it was a church group.
Swear to God trying to raise money
for something and Ooh, Oh, did,
oh Billy boy munches
fucking balls on that one.
Jesus Christ. It was a legitimate
bomb fucking wire to wire.
It just was not a stellar moment in it.
Like you ever see when a plane
goes to take off and it just,
it's just not at the right speed and just
fucking just clips the trees that like,
that's what happened. Then it
disappears into them. You're like, oh,
maybe they landed safely than this.
The fireball. That was my set.
Uh, but the other place, it was
worth it. Cause the first one,
it was magic. It was a great,
do you believe in magic?
Um, in the fucking main room.
That one was great. So, um,
I got to work with Tony V, one of
my favorites and a Yada, Yada, Yada.
At the next fucking day, I go to the,
I go to the graduation and you know,
you know the deal with
graduations, you like, oh my God,
this is going to fucking suck. All
right, this is going to be long.
This is going to be hot. It's going to
be hot and long. It's going to suck.
It sounds like a fucking point over
here. It's horrific. All right.
And a pleasant surprise.
We show up. It's indoors,
it's fucking air conditioning.
The Dean comes out,
she starts fucking talking crushes it,
brings up some political guy.
He goes up, fucking crushes it. Then
they bring up the guest speaker.
All right.
This is like when a basketball teams
going on a run and everybody's standing up
freaking out.
That eight Tevo rather are the sole Ipos,
the fucking speakers,
a crushing it.
Then they bring up the guy that they hired
to speak and he comes fucking walked.
Dr Barack Obama, blue, blue, blue,
whatever the fuck his name is.
He comes walking up. This is how
we started his speech. He goes,
before I speak,
I would like to say something.
I swear to God,
that's what he said.
That's one of the greatest fucking
lines I ever heard before I speak.
I would like to say something
and immediately are just
sitting there going like,
Oh God,
this is going to be at least
47 to 52 fucking minutes of
absolute fucking boredom at,
uh, fortunately I was Ra like
most of my NHL picks. I was wrong.
This guy crushed it. It, oh, sorry.
Talking about being a little kid
and born in fucking Nazi Poland,
Nazi occupied Poland, Poland, excuse me,
and how the fuck you got out of their
survivor's guilt and how have you become a
lawyer?
You don't have to be a fucking content.
You can actually work pro bono and help
change the world for a better plane.
It was a great speech.
Crushed it.
Right now all of a sudden they
handle out diplomas. I'm like,
Holy Shit, they're going to
get this fucking thing done
in two and a half hours.
This is going to be great.
Fucking great.
And then we're out to
the fucking bears in the,
in the food and everything's great.
They hand them all out and that's it.
And then the dean comes back and
inexplicably starts fucking talking.
Okay,
keep talk.
10 minutes later,
still fucking talking and a,
and everybody getting restless
and it's just like, what the fuck?
What the fuck is this person doing?
And then like 15 minutes in,
it was so bad.
It just started to become funny.
I mean,
everybody was running for her,
wrap it up in 30 seconds and 15 minutes
and she goes, I'm going to tell this.
This is just an aside.
And she told the fucking side story that
had nothing to do with the other story
and all this shit she was saying was
basically what everybody else had said.
Yeah,
20 minutes, 25 minutes in, 30
minutes in. And I swear to God, dude,
I like I started, I started getting
angry because I was all the way in,
up against the wall. I was starting to
feel trapped and I started thinking,
she's doing this on purpose. This is a
fucking power trip. And then mercifully,
it fucking finally ended
like 35 minutes later,
35 fucking minutes later.
And she didn't have a clue
how much she was annoying
the shit out of everybody.
The only thing that was keeping me
going was looking around at people.
People were doing everything.
People were,
were just sort of sitting there like
looking at the side of their head at the
person next to them. A couple
other people had done that. Uh, uh,
what's known as the confessional posts
or you're seated and you've got your
elbows on your knees and your head is
hanging in, your hands are clasped.
There was a lot of that going on.
There was a other people
not even trying to hide it,
looking around behind them like a
year fucking shitting me that look
not just over the right shoulder,
left shoulder to right fucking
double threat with that.
There was people, I was
right near, uh, the section,
I wasn't near the wall near the railing
and then that was like an exit right
next to me. And this one fuck guy,
he walked in, walked out, walked in,
walked out, walked into third time and
he literally put his hands out like,
you know, like one of the reps make a
fucked up. The call itself fucked up.
Even the head coach doesn't even know it
is. And then they're talking about it,
trying to get it right and they've come
to a decision and they don't inform the
coach and he just kind of puts his hands
out like the fuck Hap, what? What's,
what's going on? Am I
getting fucked her mom? I am,
I am I going to come
out all right in this.
So literally just doing that and
then finally she wrapped it up.
It was still a good time. It was
still a good graduation. But, uh,
I dunno that Dean, I swear to God, it
was just like my performance of giggles.
I should've stopped at the first little
performance. I should've ended it.
That it was just, it was
horrific. Okay. So anyways,
the next day I ended up
going down to Nashville.
I just realized I haven't written in my
fucking advertising it for this week.
God dammit.
I went down to Nashville for the
Vince Vaughn Wild West comedy, uh,
festival,
the first one,
hopefully not the last time cause it was
such a great time and I got to play the
Ryman theater and I didn't realize
that was the original Grand Ole Opry.
And uh,
I'm going to tell you about that right
after these messages from our sponsor.
I know. Fuck you too. Fuck you. Go Fuck
Yourself. I got to do these. All right.
Dollar Shave Club. Darla Dollar
Shave Club. Everybody, you know,
there are so many things
that pissed me off.
Talk about a few things to
piss you off, Bill. Okay,
let's talk about all the fucking dean
should have wrapped it up the first time
and instead goes on for 35 minutes.
That pisses me off.
You know there did I read,
reach my contractual obligation there.
All right. And paying way too much to
shave. My face is definitely up there too.
Right up there with somebody doing 35
minutes when I was done with you with your
first seven. Okay. Nothing feels better
than shaving with a fresh new blade,
but new razors are so ridiculously
expensive that you can't afford to change
your blade more than once every six weeks,
six months or so.
You'll end up scraping up
your face with the old blade.
Dollar Shave club delivers top quality
raises for only a few bucks a month.
Dollar Shave Club members always shave
with a fresh blade because they get a
fresh pack in the mail every
God damn week. Um, they got,
they got lots of other
products to all its back.
Everybody liked Dr
Covey's easy shave balm.
Dr Cavities, Post Shave. Oh,
he's expanding the business.
Well, he also asked to have a
far, he's got a doc to Kat doctor.
I got to work on my Boston accent.
Talk to cabbies post shave,
which follows is easy shave butter.
Um,
I want some easy shave butter for my
toast when it'd be nice easy butter.
Uh, join the hundreds of thousands of
guys who've upgraded to a smarter way to
shave, shave time, shave money.
Join the dollar shave club.com/join
now@dollarshaveclubdotcomslashburrsupportthiscuppodcastandagreatcompanybygoingtodollarshaveclub.com
slash bird that's dollar shave
club.com/ [inaudible] all right,
he voice everybody. You're a business
owner. I'm that. You're a business owner,
but automated phone systems
and secretaries are not
in your budget just yet.
And juggling incoming calls can really
make you sound and look a little bit
unprofessional. Is there
a solution? Yes there is.
Here's something that will
dramatically help you and make your,
make you more money in 2014 it's a voice.
Everybody,
whether you're a business of one on 100
easy voice will help you manage all of
your incoming calls with a
toll free number, dial by name,
directory and call routing tools. Your
business will sound like 1 million bucks.
Can't take a call, no biggie. He voice.
We'll transcribe the voicemail
and email it directly to you.
Never be caught off guard again and with
the voice you can try it before you buy
it right now. Just for my listeners and
anybody else that they've paid money to,
read this. You can get a 60 day trial
to eve voice for absolutely free.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the
Promo Code Bill B I l l at checkout.
Take charge of your business and make
more money in 2014 go to he voice.com and
enter bill at checkout for
your 60 day free trial.
That's [inaudible] dot com
Promo Code Bill. All right,
one more legal zoom,
legal zoom. Everybody.
Modern technology is phenomenal.
Smartphones,
I pads and other gadgets make
it easy to do so many things,
but why is it that our lives seem to
get vizier at the same time? Well,
when it comes to getting
the legal help you need,
legal zoom provides a great solution
that works with your busy schedule.
Let's face it,
the legal system is complicated.
There are better things you can do with
your time. Thankfully, thank Christ.
Legal Zoom is there for you. So if you're
thinking about starting a business,
forming an LLC or getting a trademark,
what will or a living trust,
legal zoom gets the job done right?
You'll get the personal attention you
need and they'll help you take care of all
the details.
Legal Zone's been helping families and
small business owners for 14 years and
they received an a plus from
the better business bureau.
Call or visit legal zoom
today for an extra discount.
Enter bur bur and their
referral code at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com/burr legal zoom
provides legal help through independent
attorneys and self help services,
but it is not a law firm.
Go to legalzoom.com enter discount code
bur bur are all right back to the damn
podcast. So I mentioned, I played the
Ryman theater, which isn't in downtown.
It's in what I consider the downtown.
It's right with the
Nashville predators play.
They got all the Honky tonks
there and they got all the play.
I don't know if they call them
that anymore, whenever all that,
all the fucking country music
and all that shit. And uh,
and right around the corner, right off
this little street is the Ryman theater.
And um,
that's where the original Grand Ole
Opry was at from like 1930 something to
1974. And, um,
basically who was anybody
got to perform even before then, before
he was even the Grand Ole Opry. It was a,
uh, of, of Vaudeville, um,
space. So all these other guys,
you know, I imagine Charlie Chaplin,
I mean, he was doing the rounds.
He was working the road buster Keaton,
WC fields, they had his, his, uh,
headshot. I'm hanging in
there. So we've got see that,
that's how much history this place,
even when the people that I'm
freaking out about the Hank Williams,
you know, ah, patsy Cline and all of
them, even when they perform there,
that place was already legendary. And, um,
they actually had a couple strips
of wood from the original stage.
So everybody who came out to perform
had to go and step on them and distinct
that, you know, you know, all
these unbelievable performance,
uh, had been there. And, um,
I'm not going to lie to you.
It was one of the best shows
I've had in my entire career.
I don't know what happened.
I went out there and, uh,
usually it takes me a second to get a
little warmed up, get a vibe for the room.
But I walked out there and
they used to be a church,
so they have all the original pews.
It was made in like 1898,
so they still had all the original pews.
Um,
I'm telling you right now, if you
go to Nashville, you gotta go,
you gotta go see a fucking show there.
There's a bunch of other
great venues there and stuff,
but you got to go like I heard
Neil young played there, um,
recently. I mean that's one that I
would just stop what I was doing,
get on a plane to go to the Ryman theater
and just sit in a fucking pew from
1898 and watched Neil young.
I mean that's just incredible.
So somehow a shit head like me told
enough Dick Jokes and next thing you know,
I'm the next guy on the show.
So I walk out there and the sun's
going down and up in the upper deck.
It's really small.
Lots smaller than I thought it was going
to be because people were smaller back
then and they pack them in
and there wasn't all this
extra crap luxury boxes and
everything.
So
whatever it was like a 2000 seat or
1800 seater and it was the size of like,
I swear to God, like a lot of 500
seat theaters. It's unbelievable.
We're literally tripled the fucking size
of these people, I guess. So anyways,
up top, they had these stained glass
windows so the sun was going down.
All right.
The sunlight's coming through
the stained glass windows,
it looks like the fucking
blues brothers moment. And uh,
I went out there and it was
a great crowd and I was on,
I started talking,
they started laughing and I swear to God,
I almost did like two hours.
I'd be like an hour and 45 minutes and
I left out like three huge bits then I'm
going to do on my special.
MMM.
You know,
you gotta have your blocks.
When I put together a new hour
and I feel like I got the,
I got it
together is you need that big opener,
got to have the big closer.
And then you got to have like,
you got to have three or four
big ones in the middle, you know,
and then you got your little ones,
you give him the rest,
then you go back new big one,
give a little wrestling,
give him to take up on a little ride.
Um,
but you got to have like you got to
have the four corners there to build the
structure is how I view it.
I Dunno.
I Dunno why I don't have
a good science background,
but that's how I fucking viewed the thing.
And um,
I dunno. I, I've had so much fun.
I'm having more fun than
I ever had doing standup,
so I have more than enough at this point.
And um,
that's the only concern
I have when I go to tape.
This thing is I don't
want it to be overly long,
but I also want to document those jokes
so I don't know what I'm going to do
either do all of them and then cut the
special and then have those as extras.
I have no fucking clue how I'm
going to do it. But you know what,
it's a great fucking problem to have.
So anyways,
backstage and you can take a tour of
this is they have up on the third floor,
they have the Johnny Cash room and they
have the Hank Williams room and then you
go down the floor beneath it.
They have second floor. They have.
That's where all the womens
are because men are better.
We're above on floor number three.
And then on floor number two,
they had like the Patsy Cline.
I'm the Patsy Cline room.
And then, uh, what else was the fucker?
I'm just so bad at country stars.
This is really bad.
I have no fucking idea who they hit.
I'm sorry.
I just painted the whole picture
and then just drop the brush.
Just let you guys fall right off
the fucking canvas. I'm sorry,
I don't remember, but it was
fucking amazing. I actually went,
I actually came out to Patsy Cline
when I was there. I know it's hacking.
It's touristy, but uh, it was cool.
I've always liked her. And um,
there's actually rumors that she stayed
on the street that I live in out,
uh,
live on out here in la.
There's rumors that she actually rented
a house on the block that I live on. And,
uh,
that's one of the really cool things to
completely make a left turn here about
living in Los Angeles is if you are
in an area with a bunch of old houses,
there's going to be somebody
fucking lived in it at this point.
Hollywood and people trying to make movies
as we're coming up on a hundred years,
aren't we? Um, as far as
it actually getting going,
Hollywood land and all that type of shit,
this, do you know that there, there's a,
there's a house,
um,
I actually read about
when it was for sale.
MMM.
Somewhere here in Hollywood are, maybe
it's, I don't know what the fuck it is,
but basically the person
who owned the house,
they owned it during a prohibition and
then it had a pool and an a cabana.
So it's during prohibition. And he now
the deal, what if they outlawed boost?
I mean,
how quickly would that be a black market?
And you'd be fucking drinking in
somebody seller, you know, knocking,
you know, what's the password?
The password is a, you know,
23 Skidoo or whatever and you
fucking get in. Right. So, um,
this person made a bar,
uh,
they turned their Cavana into like a
bar and they just built this little bar.
And then I don't know if they even made
their beer in the bathtub or they had
some sort of hook up who knows what and
all these famous people from way back in
the day, Louie Armstrong, Humphrey
Bogart, all these people or whatever,
mmm.
Went over there and drank and they all
carved their names into the bar and it's
still there.
So when you went to go look at the house,
you could actually go look at this piece
of history and it's actually protected.
Like they make sure if you buy the house,
like you can't tear it down or sell
it or any of that type of shit. So,
mmm.
All of these fucking, you
know, all these icons,
they had to fucking live somewhere.
So anyways,
the rumor is the urban myth on the street
that I live on is that she either on
this street and the next
street overstayed in a house,
rented it while she was doing,
I don't know what. So it
was kind of cool. Anyways,
to come back out, uh, to come out with a,
can you tell I flew today. I'm always
out of my fucking mind when I fly,
my brain's all over the place. I've
had a fucking brutal day. I apologize.
Do you know when I, when I went to the
airport this morning, Nashville, and, uh,
it was this extra long line and you
don't just stand there and I left enough
time where I could get through it and um,
I'm coming up right to where you begin
disrobing and all that shit. Right.
And um,
yeah,
they end up, uh, the lovely Nia.
What's going on? How are you?
I'm telling my, uh, my airport
story from this morning.
So, uh, no, not even that
one. He has his, his story.
So I'm standing in line.
Does long fucking security line
Jesus bill, get to the point. I know.
So I'm getting ready to,
it's becoming my turn.
Why get to fucking take off the belt
and the sneakers and fucking get through
the damn thing. And all of a sudden
I hear this person behind going,
excuse me, thank you for giving me skill
needs. Cannes means killing Sharon.
Sharon and I turned around and it's
this guy and he's pushing this African
American woman who's in her 50s,
in a wheelchair. So you know,
I step aside, she goes by,
and then the dude behind me
goes, he said, he goes,
I got to say that exactly what he said.
He goes,
they should have to wait in line like
everybody else. That's what he said.
He went with they,
he went with they,
so they they a day meaning people in
wheelchairs or black people flag I
think. No, I think he met wheelchairs
because those other black people, um,
uh, standing in line.
Right. So, so I turn around.
Yeah.
And I, I don't talk to fucking people
want it and he just, it was just so crazy.
I just try, I said, come on man. I
mean, she's in a wheelchair. I go,
would you rather be standing
up and sitting in that chair?
And then there was a pause and he goes,
they should wait in line
like everybody else,
like his whole Mississippi burning
vibe and we know it's killing me.
I came up,
I came,
I came up with the fucking line that I
should have said after I got on the plane,
what I should have said, ah, what the
fuck was it? And I already forget.
What did I got to have the proper word.
My brain is just not working today. Um
Oh that's, I'm like, oh, now you
believe in quality. It's not a quality.
What does the word now you believe in a,
okay.
Oh Jesus, I just blew
it. No, I'm completely,
no, I'm completely fucking
out of it. What the fuck is,
cause he's basically, you know, this
guy, he doesn't want shit to be equal.
But now that she's going by him, now he
wants to shit to be equal. But you know,
if she went to live in his fucking
neighborhood, he wouldn't want it to be.
So he wants to quality. Oh, that was
on sale. Now you believe in equality.
That's what I was going
to say. Yeah. Jesus. Okay.
You just looked up and
you get what I'm saying.
It's always a great joke when you have
to overly explain it to someone who's
known you for fucking
years. Ah, Jesus. All right,
so she see how that just bombed
everybody? Maybe a pip. It's a good thing.
I didn't say it.
Um,
that's basically what my second
set had giggles was like, oh,
I didn't tell you that. And
yeah, I fucking ate my balls. No,
I did wired to I,
there was one woman's was so disgusted
she wouldn't look at me and I just kept
saying, I'm not going to tell another
joke to you. Look at me. And she,
she wouldn't look and I kept going,
I'm not going to tell another joke.
She looked at me and she just goes,
yeah.
And continued to look down at the floor
and she was like, you know, 65 70.
Well that's not exactly your
demographic. They were, they were,
they were a church group trying to raise
money and nobody told me I need. So,
yeah, that's, that was my out. That's
my app. That's the story I'm telling.
So anyways, so he was
my morning. All right.
So I get a car service to pick
me up at lax when I go to land.
Now the whole fucking purpose of a car
service, when you get off the plane,
the fucking jerk office standing there.
So you just leave,
you want to leave, you paying a ridiculous
amount of money, not for the ride.
You paying the money to
leave to leave the cluster.
Fuck that is lax.
So I go down there and there's 10 people
standing there with names and I'm all
excited is my name. We had a
name. Did I get picked right?
Am I going to make varsity?
You know,
and of course my name is and fucking
there Jarman entitled Jack Ass at this
point. So I'm like, you
know what? Fuck that.
I just walk out and I go right
to the cab line. There's no line.
There's also no caps,
but I see a cab common and the fucking
guy pulls up and then right then I get
the text about the guy and he's like,
you know,
trying to explain to me that he's in
the parking lot and he's on his way,
but his English is as good as my French.
So it takes a second.
So I walk away from the cab,
then I'm standing in a modern gun.
He's fucking Goddamn sons of bitches.
You know what the fuck I want to
get out of here. I want to go home.
I got to record the podcast and
being a big baby basically. Right.
And then all of a sudden, two seconds
later, the fucking town car pulls up.
He looks at me, I look at him, I nod,
he nods and I fucking get in the car.
And I'm like, all right,
I see. Once again, Bill,
you lost your shit for no reason
that it didn't take long at all.
So we're driving away with driving
away and I'm in a great fucking mood.
I get out of lax,
I'm feeling great.
And then all of a sudden his phone
fucking rings and he's like, hello,
what? Oh my God, I'm
so sorry. And he goes,
I picked up the wrong passenger. So
I'm thinking like, well, you know,
top too bad for that other guy.
So the guy slows down and he goes,
we have to go back until we were like
10 minutes away from the airport, right?
I'm like, we're not going back.
We can't go back. And he goes, no.
He goes, we have to go back. I got to go
back and get him. You're in the wrong car.
And I'm like, well that's not my
fault. You picked me up. Right.
And then he's literally started to turn
around. I feel like some little kid,
I want to go ahead and type stores.
Right?
And he's taking me to go see
the dentist. So I'm like, dude,
you can't just drive me back. He can't do
that. And he didn't get, he starts going,
you know, stop yelling at me and
I'm like, I'm not yelling at you.
Like he thought this was yelling.
That's not yelling, is it? Well,
you know what,
you guys need to up your yelling gang
cause that's not fucking yelling. So
Aye, he apologizes. The other guy doesn't
fucking apologize to me. And he goes,
I had to sign any shows.
A sign was like fucking guy's last name.
It was like Rancho Cucamonga, this
really fucking long name. And I'm like,
I didn't even fucking show me that.
He goes, yes I did. I go, dude,
you're literally telling me I don't
know what my name is. And he's like,
stop yelling at me. I go, I'm not yelling.
And you're sitting next acting like
I don't know what my fucking name is.
I didn't curse though. So then I finally
just go, you know what, just pull over,
let me out here.
So he pulls over and like support that
leaves me off and he's just sitting there
in the fucking driver's seat.
Okay.
As I, as I go to get out, pops the
trunk and it's just sitting there.
So I leave the passenger side door open
and the trunk open and I walk out like a
total fit. Such a chick fucking move.
Like, that's not a man move. Um,
but I did that and I went,
I got my done.
Um, it is, dude, that's
that. That's a pussy.
Move it as a footsie move, but
there you go. Who has a pussy check.
Thank you. You know the whole
thing about that scenario is his,
like his job is to say,
are you Mister Rancho Cucamonga?
Yes, I am. Are Your any we're
going to this place. Right.
That's normally what
they're supposed to do.
They've made sure you got the name
right. I had my headphones on. Okay.
I took my 50% of it all
right. Yeah, because the guy,
the driver who have the actual person
who I was at least 50% of my fault
[inaudible] was 50% of year fall because
there was a guy inside holding a sign
with your name on it. No,
there wasn't. Not at the time.
But then he called you or
whatever and he was like,
I'm coming around and this
and that. Either wet or hear
what you just said there.
What you just said.
What you said,
there was a guy in there holding a
sign with my name on it. I said no,
there wasn't. And you said not at
the time. Well, they called me.
It was the thing. Well, I call. Okay.
So if the fire department shows up the
day before the fucking house is on fire
and sprays water on it, like
it's, this isn't his job.
They supposed to have a little
bit of timing. That's why he is.
He's supposed to have time
and he should have been there.
You should have seen him right away.
That's the whole point of it.
And at other jackass should have confirmed
that you were Mister Rancho Cucamonga
and you are going to the right place.
So I'm staying Rancho Cucamonga.
I said in the beginning and I thought I
would go with some different like Walla
Walla Walla are chubby chase.
Uh, I'm joking, but the the,
so now he should have checked.
He fucked up.
Can I say you got all I fucked up the
way you fish kid and kid, I fucked up.
I'm a dick.
He probably told the story to the next
passenger and they both laughed and the
next passenger was easy going and fucking
was, was a better person than I wasn't.
Gave him a nice, but he messed up. He hit,
he was supposed to check to make sure.
And you've never met the
person before you doubled.
Sort of assumed I was that dumb.
That's basically it.
I should have closed the door
in the trunk. I'm a content.
Has a bit of a bitch move. Totally.
Well there you go. So you agree with me?
No I but bitch meaning like
busy but not a female necessary.
Well it's not fair. It's not fair
to plunk move. Maybe this, no.
Anna pitch 50 like having a fit or
throwing a tantrum like a baby ish move.
Oh definitely mature. Immature.
All about it. We'll go in immature.
It was an immature move of you to be like,
well why I'm not closing the
door or the trunk. Take that.
You're both being like unnecessary
because he should have been like,
you know what sir? You're
absolutely right. I should
have double checked with you.
I'm so sorry. I got 20 bucks on me. Can I
at least give you $20 for the next doll?
He doesn't do all of that.
Look at this and this.
I think this is why it's called
a chick move. A pussy move.
A bitch move is because
guys are progressive.
We cause you guys don't
fight for the most part.
You guys don't solve shit
physically. So you guys, you solve
it that way cause you're,
you're more evolved as a man.
You're supposed to flake.
I was literally supposed to,
supposed to take off my fucking headphones
and we were supposed to Duke it out
right there on the sidewalk and whoever
won that was the direction the car was
going to go in.
Every Clint Eastwood movie I ever watched.
That's how it was supposed to be done.
And I did all right.
I was like tootsie. That's
what the movie was like. So,
but you still understand that he did
have to go back to get the person who
actually paid for his
car. He, he screwed up.
But he has to go back and get
the person that paid for the car.
Okay.
He can't call another car. Well, I don't
know what their whole situation is. He,
I don't think you know anything about
the situation because you don't work in
that industry. Well, I just know that,
isn't it enough that I just said I was
100% wrong and that I was a bitch and I
threw a tantrum and he just gonna fucking
countersink it and fucking hell no
spackle over it. I got it.
I'm fine. I know you had a
hard morning. I'm not going to
come in here the whole weekend.
Yeah.
I swear to God like I was a fucking
idiot this weekend. I got on,
I returned a rental car at Logan
Airport and I miss my fucking missed my
terminal because I assumed that something
in Boston with the sign was going to
make sense, which it never
does. This is the deal. I'm,
I'm waiting to go to terminal e
southwest airlines. Right. So they go,
the first one, there's two buses.
One goes to BNC, one goes to DNA,
so I don't fuck that up.
I actually get on the right bus.
They go to the first one. They're
like terminal dean, fuck in whatever.
United Airlines
the south like,
well that's not a day. I
know it's not d. And I was,
I was tweeting once again being a
fucking idiot. So while you were driving,
not while I was writing,
but here's the thing in between Charles,
that was terrible. So we get to the
next terminal. Okay, I'm in a bus.
I couldn't see what the letter was and
it says, uh, it says next to, you know,
next term when he starts, all I
hear is that the airlines, Japanese,
their Iraqi air, Turkish air,
United, Arab Emirates. I'm like,
all right, international terminal,
blah blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then all of a sudden
we're going back to the,
where the fuck I was going to go. Well,
what happened term leader? The guy goes,
I want it to terminally southwest
the International. Does that make any
fucking sense? Japanese air, Turkish air,
Iraqi air, south west,
then somebody by southwest.
So didn't a bigger airline by southwest.
Is that have anything to do with it?
I thought I heard that. I
thought southwest got bought
by some bigger airline.
What are you hanging out with?
Pilots? No, fuck. Do you know that?
I don't know cause I read
things. I Dunno. I am.
I really could have sworn at that happen.
Okay.
You know what's funny about you?
You don't want to get a fuck anyway.
Wanted to bring this up.
How you don't want to get a TV in the
bedroom because you said it affects the
connection between the two people.
I'm keeping it clean here and meanwhile,
every fucking night, you know, you're,
you're on your laptop. So what's
the point? Why can't I watch the,
the end of a game laying there in bed,
rubbing my bulls,
watching a game. There's another, there's
nowhere in here to hang a television.
Well, they used to have these things
back in the day called TV stance.
And when you bought a TV that no, that's
not gonna be a TV stand in here. No,
I don't at all. That's hilarious.
I thought I had 50% of this room.
Can I be on my side of
the room then? Um, no.
I literally blocked the door to my
closet with a TV. If I could just do it.
Do you want to like it right there and
have the door closed so we can like see
it on an angle? I mean, that could
work. That's not a crazy idea.
It's not a crazy idea. It's one of the
best ideas you've ever had. Thank you.
I'll get rid of that closet door.
You're not,
you're not going to get rid of the closet.
I'll fucking open that. God. Let's be,
let's close the door.
Let's be serious here.
I'll play another man who knows how to
fix things. To open that wall up there.
My entire closet into a fucking TV.
That whole walls a TB.
Most people make it in an aquarium,
right?
Like obsessed with lying down
while watching TV. Tired.
Fucking tired.
My brain doesn't work anymore.
I've traveled more and the last fucking
year and a half and I'm old now. Okay.
I'm fucking old. I forgot. I
lost another pair of sunglasses.
I left my car charger. I
just drop off. Rent a car.
I just get out of the car.
Yeah, I mean I shouldn't.
I should be wearing those
hospital loafers carrying an ivy,
but that should be like I told you too
that all of would tag is a phone call and
they were like, no, we don't see it then
fine, you move on. But if they're like,
actually yeah,
I just went out to the glove compartment
and there they were working on,
I left my sunglasses in a Vegan
restaurant in the dude stole them. Okay.
It's still sad about that, huh? There's
something about a Vegan restaurant.
Why You keep tying veganism to like your,
your a to,
you know, they're like, what? Sufferable
people out there. No offense vegans,
but you know you guys can be too much.
Oh Shit. I said, hey,
you know what people wanted me to
talk about Jay z and Salon Juror. Oh,
the elevator fail. Whatever the hell
are fucking name. That's a name.
I'm sick of Jay z wearing that.
Roger Moore Tuxedo. We get it.
You're fucking cool enough already.
Tom Ford. Oh, is that what that is?
I always feel at this point,
Jay z so famous,
you forget he's from Brooklyn and he
fucking grew up in a street corner.
Can still beat the shit out of you.
Although him with his shirt off, you know,
I don't know.
He's definitely a businessman
either. Yeah, exactly.
He's fine dining,
eating like steak and wine and like
[inaudible] I can tell you this.
I need to do all,
he's got the gift of Gab lab.
He doesn't need to do all of it. Doesn't,
it doesn't, you know, I've, I've, I've had
enough arguments with people.
God bless him and his Roger Moore Tuxedo.
Did you talk about the elevator
fight? Have you Kinda I,
I, I, I'll talk about it.
Oh, I'll talk about it. Write down.
I thought Jay z regardless of whatever
the fuck he said that set her off showed
unbelievable restraint.
Okay.
Getting kicked by a woman in high
heel shoes. I've been there. Okay.
That five fucking hurts.
And he kept taking it to the hands
and there was a moment at one,
I only watched it once. There was a time,
like one of the last times she hit him,
she even flinched cause she was like,
yeah at this point he decided to
deserve to get punched in the face.
You see her flinch,
she spit at him.
That was what was really awful.
That's what I forgot to do
to that driver this morning.
That would have been like Browning
bitch move nine. Never do that.
But you know their family has
problems like anybody else's family.
I feel like if anything it just,
you know,
it just goes to show you
that you shouldn't feel bad
when you know your uncles
or whatever started screaming
at each other over thanksgiving.
That is funny though,
when you really think about how many
people are at tour judging them.
Actually this footage that exists
somewhere of their family fighting in an
elevator, it's just they're not
famous and nobody cares. So it's,
it just gets taped over.
I feel like a lot of,
there are a lot more like physical
fights that happen in families between
siblings and stuff that
most people wouldn't want to
admit. You know? So it's, I,
it's, I really don't think
it's that big of a deal.
I was watching it like salons stop.
No,
definitely said something fucked up
because you definitely has Beyonce did do
anything. She, she was, she
was staying with her sister.
She was probably like, wow,
that's what happens when you say
x, Y and z. That was her vibe.
Uh, yeah. So, but I, I, it's not that big
of a deal. I don't feel like, you know,
well that's kind of a big no, that's
a tough, that's, that's, it's over.
Their relationship is fucking over.
And if money wasn't involved,
whose relationship? Jay Z's and
uh, the fucking large, yeah,
those sidekick there. She's
not, yeah, she is. Come on
Frank. Frank Stallone. No, no.
She has a really good album.
I love her music and she has great style.
No,
she thoughts me miss as Beyonce obviously
and all these dumb ass Internet people
on Twitter are like, I've never
even heard words. Who knows?
You should be thankful she got any car.
This is my nice theory because you don't
know music beyond what's on your top 40
radio station.
And they play in the morning while you're
going to work doesn't mean that this
person isn't talented.
No,
I just get annoyed with that is first
of vegans down the music lovers,
this is the deal.
The only way she can make it as if she's
in the same group is Beyonce because
that's the way it fucking works.
There's no way.
Never in the history of two people in
the same family trying to be a solo
artists. Have they ever made it?
They always, you got to be together.
The Everly brothers,
the Jackson five,
the Osmonds and then what
happens is somebody breaks
out of it and then the rest
of them go back to the dinner table going,
I have an album out to whenever.
He's like, yeah, we don't care. I
know I'm your mother. I don't care.
Michael is special.
Donny and Marie are the best.
They're younger than you.
They're cuter than you and Jesus likes
them better and that's what happens and
you're fucked.
So the only move she had was
when Beyonce was on the way up.
She should have been in Destiny's child.
Look at me.
Look at me on the other side of the fence,
just calling off groups here.
Wow. Was she in that group? She was like,
I thought it was Kim Coles and a
that chick from Cole from uh, uh,
the one in the roller skates
today wasn't she had that
name and black people now. Yeah. Um,
now she was like a backup dancer.
She went on tour with
them when she was younger.
She had an album when she was younger.
She got pregnant. She, Matt Cutts.
They're like, I was in Oklahoma
as a backup dancer. I was,
remember that ACDC,
that ACDC video who made,
who when I had all the Angus is up there.
I was, well, I was one of the Angus six.
She, I know she also, I didn't
really, I didn't know. I wish I did.
She also wrote quite a few of Beyonce
songs and I co wrote some of destiny shots
on it. So you know, she's, she's got
other talents, things, you know. Yeah.
She's seven.
She's like that.
She's like that chick and I say,
hey,
now go in. And her name is Linda. No,
it is it is it called Jessica.
So you know I'm right.
I don't know what her name
is. Four non blondes. Yeah.
Lead or Linda Perry recently married
to Sarah Gilbert from Roseanne.
Did you know that you could play
Darlene? They're, they're married.
The last time I saw Linda Perry,
not the last time, like I see her,
but I saw her blonde chick.
Isn't she like fuck she's
gotta be my age probably.
What's she going around with that
little girl for what he's talking about?
Sarah Gilbert is older than I
and I saw the show the other day.
She's like 12th that's
cause she looks great.
Like I was watching the fucking TV show
just bombing all over the place.
But now I saw Linda Perry at the rest
of the Vegan restaurant in question.
Oh yeah. I hope she didn't leave
her fucking sunglasses or a top hat.
I did not. You like her Linda Perry. Oh,
because I had a problem with white
people with dreadlocks. Dammit.
Fucking snuffed that right out.
You're too smart for
your own fucking yeah.
Good. She doesn't have them anymore. Yeah.
But she had a young writer,
Nia doesn't like white people with dreads
where it's like she doesn't like wet
weds. I just feel like, I don't know,
tread lugs are a very particular
cult. I don't know. Maybe they don't,
that style doesn't
belong to anyone anymore.
You considered it an off
shoot of blackface? I, no,
I think it's like,
you know,
white people that don't want to do their
hair and like think they're super, um,
like tapped into like roster reggae
music and like what if they really fat?
Really? What if they really, really,
really love weed that, yeah,
that doesn't mean anything. That,
and they actually normally do really,
really,
really love weed with the goddamn
hemp necklaces and whatnot.
So it's another commitment
to the lifestyle.
That's not all Rastafarianism is though.
It's a religion.
No, it isn't. Yes it is. Google
it not in this country. Well,
it's one of their holidays.
And how can we don't get the
day off because it's not,
it's not an American thing. You said it's
not, not in this country. It's actually,
no, I was joking. I was
just being an idiot. But no,
it's not an like an American or
whatever religion. No, it isn't. No,
but this aren't there enough rosters over
here that they could start complaining
and we could get another day off.
Y'All mine,
I've come. The Jews got
all that days off. Sorry.
Worst fucking Jamaican accent ever.
Is that what Rastafarian's come from?
I Dunno. All I know is I
wouldn't fuck with any of them.
I don't believe in magic.
Do you believe in magic?
But I do with fucking those people.
I wouldn't fuck with them.
I saw nothing. Magic. I've
watched stuff voodoo. Yeah,
cause that's not the same place.
It's all Raiders of the lost ark to
me the same thing at all. Listen,
they stay still. They still use to
you, aren't they? Yeah, I went there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's threatening.
stamps.com everybody you
want to do whatever it takes
to make sure your business
runs efficiently.
Course you do.
But constant trips to the post
office can definitely get in the way.
Eats up valuable time it could be
spending on growing your business instead.
So bring the post office right back to
your desk with stamps.com you don't have
to be a postal expert.
Stamps Dot coms makes it easy.
Buy and print official US postage for
any letter or any package using what you
already have,
your own computer and printer.
Then just hand it to your
mail man or mail person.
It's just that easy. Join over,
join the five soon. So great.
Join the 500,000 small businesses
that use stamps.com and never have.
Go to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs
and my posters for all the stuff that I
whore myself out with at the end of
the show. I'm a moron if I can use it.
So can you right now use my last name,
birth for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus
offer includes a digital
scale and up to $55 free
postage. Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
and to
burn, that wasn't bad was
it? Hey, you know what?
I forgot to mention now the ultimate PC.
We've covered it all.
Mail carrier. I know,
but that job's not going to
exist in a couple of years.
The phase and the whole
frigging thing out. Um,
and back in the day they had a mail
man. Um, all right, wait a second.
I needed to promote something
here. Oh, people, oh,
I haven't got to the fucking questions
this week. Um, oh, people always ask,
where can I email the podcast?
This is where you can do it at bill.
Sorry, Bill at the [inaudible]
podcast.com. Once again,
bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com.
Okay. Day you go. And
on Twitter you can also,
if you want to look up some of the clips
and shit at the mm podcast and MMP in
both things is capitalized.
Now they have to rewind both whatever
the fuck it takes. All right, Stan hope.
Um, tons of emails about
the standup episode. Lots of
kind words from listeners,
insane amounts of requests
for him to come back. It's,
we need him to say thank you for the
flowers, but he never treated me back,
but he has also a gazillion followers,
so he probably didn't even
see him as he did. He brought
you that, uh, the Nice, uh,
it's not a bouquet. He bites
you. A potted plant. Yeah.
He bought you the flowers that keep
given and the little floral arrangement.
I put it out on my little back and either
for some reason he thought that you
weren't going to like, like he was
going to be, I don't know what,
like a bad influence.
He would've loved them.
Came in absolutely killing this
fucking leisure suit. He looked great.
He was wearing a leisure suit.
I missed him. And then he
never met him, but he sounds cool and he's
really funny and so, oh yeah. Meet him.
Really flooding is an understatement.
He's been like, you know,
anybody who says that's the funniest
guy in the country for the last,
at least eight years. I, I
would never, I would just say,
you have great taste in comedy. Now. Get
Out of my way. I'm trying to find my car.
Oh, entitled bill this week.
All right. Dare Billy faithful.
You and Nia seemed to have a great
relationship from the listeners.
Point of view. Uh,
couples always play that.
If you could shoot with anyone who would,
uh,
why did you have to show up for this? Who
would it be game? I'm asking you this.
If you could have one woman from all of
history. I love when people say that.
Like you have any idea when that what,
what like Joan of arc look like?
You just what the way she,
that she was painted women were
fucking ugly back in the day. Oh,
stop it. And the guys were, everybody
was shaped like a refrigerator.
That's why I hate those old photos.
When your pictures, the paintings,
when you go there,
all those fucking rump roast.
Everybody just fucking
how many wars did you win?
How are you like get on, just go walk
around the castle a couple of times. Yeah,
fuck out. Fine Art or Web implies
those people were just there. Yeah.
Live in the life,
eating good food and being served as,
and they just sat around
pasty fat thighs and asses.
They didn't have to do anything
as the people out in the field.
Those were the people who had gray
bodies. But the aristocrats, yeah,
there's just kind of, you
know, they're turning into
mush as you like to say. Yeah.
Okay,
well we should have painted the poor
people because the fucking bad ass is in
the castle. They were a mess. No
wonder they wore robes. You know,
everybody else was walking around
with a fucking leaf over their junk.
All right,
I'm asking you this.
If you could have one woman from all of
history be absolutely in love with Billy
twinkle toes. Oh, it's this for you.
Who would it be? No, it's for you. Oh,
they're writing. It's him. Okay.
Assuming Nia isn't in the picture for
nonviolent reasons, who would be a girl?
Imagine you have 60 seconds to give your
answer and it's going to stick for all
n n Aternity. Uh, thanks
and go fuck yourself.
Um,
60 seconds on the clock. I know what's
fucked up is what's great about this is,
and it isn't just who do you want to bang?
I'm going to have to live with this
person when the looks go and that you want
them to be in love with you
and you have all of history.
All of history for me is every
hot woman I've seen since the 70s.
You one choice,
one choice.
There's some seventies women that you
bring up. I feel like you might still,
I liked all the Charlie. You know what?
Uh, I'd liked all the Charlie's angels,
but I could, I live with
them. Kate Jackson was,
I think the cutest one. I loved
Kate Jackson with that smokey voice.
And when she was on the rookies, what,
how much? Well, how much time I got left.
You think about 30 seconds. 30
seconds. 25. Who else did I like?
Now the smokey voice with some curves
was the chicken the beginning of a
cheers did she was on fat actress
and she looked like, oh yeah,
she's really beautiful. She's
gorgeous. She is beautiful stomach.
Very beautiful. Fuck. Um,
so Kirstie Alley circuit.
Cheers. K Jackson. So
good. Charlie's angels.
But you only get to somebody else.
I know somebody else.
This is too fucking quick. No, no, no.
I got 10 seconds. You
got to down sad. Nine.
Hey crusher,
that Marion Ross. What? Marion Ross,
who's Marion Ross played the mom
on happy days. I had nothing.
I had to go with something funny so I get
to choose just no pants. But I'm here.
I know you hear it. But the question
was it for you. Let's see. Summer baby,
summer baby, sunny, Sunny Davies,
sunny baby there when I
answered the door there, Billy,
I gotta admit that's a fucking ah no,
that's actually a good,
he has abs and he could sing,
you know,
so you get the movie star in the
Rock Star. Yeah. Jesus Christ.
Sorry. Summer baby deer. Billy SPF
1000. You get it. Cause I'm pasting,
you know, some cunt wrote me on
Twitter saying like, hey bill,
I want to take a picture at the Ryman,
but you're so pasty.
It just looked like a bunch of
clothes and uh, which is true.
I'm definitely pasty,
but here's a little tip for you.
People out there want to take
a picture during the show.
Why don't you use a fucking
camera? You know, I love,
I was always me and my pigments.
Faults rather than you and your phone.
You're taking a picture with a phone.
It's a phone.
It's a cam quarter.
It's a texting device.
It's something you can watch porno on.
Oh,
when it's also a camera trying to do too
many things. It's wearing too many hats.
You bring a fucking camera in there.
It can capture me and all my lack of
pigment. Alright, so quit blaming me.
It's your fucking phone. All
right. Big plans for this summer.
I know you live out there and the
perfect climate. No, I don't. I don't.
It gets hot as hell here in the
summertime and it catches on fire. Um,
he said for people not
soil. He said, that's funny,
but what's on tap in the months of June,
July and August,
do you ever think about getting a jet
ski and hunting sharks and the coast?
Do you have a pool?
What are you excited for or,
uh,
I am excited to not kill sharks.
I think it's disgusting that
people do that Shit. And, uh,
I think it's disgusting that people
swim in the fucking ocean. I think it's,
you shouldn't do that shit. That's
disgusting. It's reckless. Uh,
I don't have a pool. What
am I excited for? Uh,
um,
doing Mike Johnston,
another one of his workouts and
I'm leading with the left hand,
one of his drum exercises.
I'm leading with the left hand and it's
getting fucking stronger every day. And,
uh,
I'm having a hell of a time playing drums.
I'm decided to ride some
motorcycles this summer.
I'm excited to take my dog on a hike.
I'm excited to not fucking work for a
couple of months after I take my special,
other than doing the local clubs out
here to build up my next hour. Oh.
And of course, I'm also doing
the, uh, um, doing that, um,
benefit on July 14th at the
green building in Brooklyn,
New York with Jimmy Smith.
Um, James Smith, sorry.
And um,
Jimmy Smith.
Jimmy Smits fucking Nytd
blue. Um, all right,
last thing,
girlfriend. Constantly gets
hit on. Ah, Jesus Christ.
Hey Nia,
come in here for this one.
The landscapers. Oh,
Jesus Christ. All right.
The landscaper did that.
The landscape for these are the people
who actually plant the fucking tomatoes.
As you can tell,
all I do is tell jokes.
I don't fucking know
how to do anything else.
I can't even drive myself
back from the fucking airport.
I lose my sunglasses like an old man.
I have caretakers at this point,
a dear Billy red balls.
I've been with my girlfriend for around
a year and I've noticed that lots of
other men hit on her.
I mean a lot.
Now this happens almost all this almost
never happens when I'm around. Oh,
that's respectful,
but she tells me at least a few times
a week about a creepy stranger who
approaches her or cat calls,
or I have to say it makes me pretty
uncomfortable but proud at the same time.
The weird part of all this is
that why my girlfriend is Asian.
It's only older black men that
hit on her. Wow, that's weird.
She must have a fucking fat ass
or something. No disrespect.
Now we're both in college and I just got
back from four months studying abroad
in France while I was there.
She told me about a guy in a parking
garage that came up behind her and groped
her.
I told you she's got a fat ass,
a guy who stopped traffic in the middle
of downtown Atlanta just to say what's
up.
And a tutor who flat out asked if she's
single and started to insult me without
ever having met me.
Oh my God.
That's fucking awesome. I'm
sorry, but that's hilarious.
He's hitting on one of his students,
finds out he has a boyfriend. Yay. Go.
Sounds like a dose.
Yeah.
How soon before that guy
gets fired? Um, anyways,
the cashiers at Starbucks
drop comments too.
When she says they
always stare at my chest.
Yeah.
Is she trying to make me jealous?
MMM.
Well, have you conveyed to her
how that makes you feel? You know,
just say not for nothing. You
are gorgeous. I understand
why people look at you.
I mean, I looked at you, I
didn't look at you like a creep.
Yeah.
You know,
I just thought you was stunningly
beautiful and I had to talk to you and now
here we are in this relationship. But uh,
I dunno. I Dunno why she's doing that.
Do you not tell her she's
beautiful all the time?
Are you not giving her something
that she needs? So she's saying,
look at all these other people who want
me or is she just out of her fucking
mind? I don't know. Let's keep
reading now for the summer.
She's also in a study. She's also in a
study abroad program, but in Barcelona.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Who is this right now? Oh, and
even fucking, is this like a,
you guys are live in
a hell of a life here.
While they were out in a little group
exploring the city, one guy with her tried
to hold her hand and tried to play
it off is just a joke. Uh, Jesus,
I can't get mad at that.
We've all had a big swing and a miss.
What are you doing? Oh No, no, I'm just
kidding. I'm just kidding. Um, anyways,
I don't know why she tells me about these
things, but she knows, oh, she knows.
It makes you feel uncomfortable.
If I was ever there with her,
I doubt this would ever happen. But we're
unfortunately long distance until July.
I'm kind of worried because she's
under 21 but now she's in Europe,
she's able to drink and I'm
scared someone's going to
try and take advantage of
her and there's nothing I can do. Am I
crazy for having this bothered me so much?
I don't know what I can
do to stop it or even if,
or even if it would stop when I'm
with her, how do I keep them away?
Okay.
Let me ask you a question,
sir. Do you love this woman?
You know, is this the woman that
you think you're going to be with?
If you have a definite answer,
yes.
Then you need to talk to her about
this. Okay. And just say, listen,
you're a beautiful woman and I'm just
going to have to accept the fact that when
I'm not around, guys are going to
ask you out the same way I did. Okay.
But for my own sanity,
I would really appreciate it if
he didn't tell me about it. Okay.
Unless obviously somebody gropes you,
then I want to fucking find the guy
and kill him. Um, if your answer is no,
um,
you are studying abroad in France.
I just came back from there.
The most beautiful women I've ever seen
in my life per capita are over there.
You're going to be foreign. You're going
to have a fucking sexy accent to them.
Cut Your fucking losses.
Go down and buy some fucking
condoms and have at it all right.
That's, that's my suggestion. I hope
I didn't go too quickly with that.
But uh,
how do you keep them away?
You can't keep him away and when you
date a beautiful warm, when you're just,
you have to accept on some level
that guys are going to hit on him.
Ken on him hit her on her and you
can't get mad at that. That beautiful.
You did the same fucking thing.
You can't tell me before you
didn't get to know her as a person.
If you really do love her, that when you
looked at her, you didn't shoot, went gat.
Hey, you did something. You
didn't say something like that.
So, um, yeah, you know,
I don't know what to tell you.
You're going to have,
you're going to have to
find a middle ground.
If you're going to stay with this woman,
you either have to fuck in a, yeah,
you've got to convey that it's bugging
you and then make peace with the fact
that it's still going to fucking happen
on some level. All right? But, uh,
she's really young and you
must be really young too,
and you're both going to countries
where they fuck because you know,
that's what's to do over
there. I'm such an idiot, but
I'm just saying, you know, what are you
going to do Bob? It was awful. Sorry,
I just got off a fucking
plane. I tried. I tried. Um,
that's my advice. If you know what,
I'm jet lagged here. If I fucking,
somebody has some better advice,
just write it into the,
a bill@themmpodcast.com.
And, uh, I'll try and maybe
do a better job next week.
That's the podcast for this week.
Sorry. No, I got the hiccups. That's it.
Everybody got fuck yourself. Have
a wonderful, a wonderful week.
And I'm going to go watch the fucking
ranges. Play the Canadian say it.